iran
you say that uh history is interesting
but perhaps not crucial if in in the
context of individualism no i mean i
think i think there's a false dichotomy
he presented here and and that is that
one view holds that
uh you can derive any anything from a
particular historical path and a kind of
an empirical view
and if we know the history we know where
we should be tomorrow we know what what
where we should stand today and the the
other path is we ignore history we
ignore facts we know what's going on we
can derive from some
a priori axioms we can derive a truth
right now and both are false both of
those views in my view are false
and uh you know i'm rand and i i reject
uh uh both of those views and i think
the better thinkers of the enlightenment
did as well although they sometimes fall
into the trap of appearing like
rationalists and yom and i
agree on one thing and that is that kant
is is is one of uh uh you know we've
we've we've talked about this in the
past uh lex but we both hate cons we
both think kant is
is i at least think kant is probably the
the most destructive philosopher
uh since plato
uh who is pretty destructive himself but
um
and part of the problem is that kant
divorces reason from reality that is he
divorces reason from history he divorces
reason from experience because we don't
have direct experience of reality
according to cartwright we we're removed
from that direct experience but i i view
kant as the anti-enlightenment that is i
view khan's as the destroyer
of good enlightenment thinking and and
your and
acknowledge a lot of um history of
philosophy of people who do history of
philosophy view kant as the embodiment
of the enlightenment that is the the
ultimate but but i i think that's a
mistake i think both russo and kant
fundamentally their goal their mission
in life is to destroy the indictment
so my view is neither of those options
are the right option that is uh the true
reason based reason is not divorced from
reality it's quite the opposite reason
is a tool it's a faculty of identifying
and integrating
what it's identifying and integrating
the facts of reality as
as
as we know them through
sense perception or through the study of
history through what actually happened
so it's the integration of those facts
it's the knowledge of that history and
then what we do is we abstract away
principles based on what's worked in the
past what hasn't worked in the past the
consequences of different ideas
different paths different actions we
abstract away principles that then can
be universal
not always we make mistakes right we can
come up with a universal principle it
sends us it's not
but if we have the whole scope of human
history we can derive principles as we
do
in life as individuals we derive
principles that are then
truths that we can live by but you don't
do that by ignoring history you do that
by learning history by understanding
history by understanding in a sense
tradition and where it leads to and then
trying to do better and i think good
thinkers are constantly trying to do
better based on what they know about the
past and what they know about the press
you